this is great none of my staff knows
this but handy ranked every male guy
every guy on our staff in terms of looks
and yeah you know I love this cuz I love
who came in dead last I really worked on
this list I want you know number one was
will yes and that's always the case
right he is maybe the best-looking of
this group to me if you had a sex with
somebody would write I like it that he's
really straight you might wear Dockers I
could fetishize that number two was
interesting he doesn't often come up
this is fred Norris you know what I've
always always enjoyed Fred yeah and I
always thought Andy was a really nice
guy you know I think he's great number
three I don't know if you're saying
that's just because you're here because
I never end up high on a list you're a
big guy I like a big guy I know I have
always maintained that your dick is
bigger than you say unfortunately not
but go ahead number four was Richard
Christie number five was Sal
I think Richard Christie is a toss-up I
think he gets blackout and then anything
happens yeah I love a genius I love a
ginge I love a country guy is a genius
country exactly number six was John Hein
yeah he's a little chubby
I'm intrigued by the fact that he says
he doesn't masturbate and I think it's
such a lie and number seven Finn Benji
good way of it Finn Brendan right with
the people I love I thought his openness
to getting fingered number eight Jason
Kaplan number nine Scott Salem
congratulations Scott the engineer freer
number ten Ronnie because of his sexual
freedom JD and dead last Gary Dell'Abate
awesome
he's like a gay item I love Gary I did
say that the bottom five are all
basically tied yeah okay but Gary I have
developed you know Gary and Lee a little
bit which is falling into the Anderson
Cooper exactly
the brother-in-law to me a little bit
it's like you know